[Applaudissements]
à Mario Paul le ccfeu Nord aura duré
qu'un peu plus de deux heures selon les
autorités ukrainiennes l'armée russe ne
respectent pas la trêve négociée lors
des pourparlers qui devaient en profiter
pour évacuer se retrouvent une fois
encore prisonnier des bombardements
russes
Mario
Street la ville très stratégique de
Mario Paul est actuellement encerclé par
les soldats russes sa prise permettrait
à la Russie de contrôler tout le
littoral de la mère d'Azov et
permettrait la jonction des troupes
venus de Crimée et celle du dombases la
situation est très tendue comme en
témoigne ces images filmées par des
journalistes Ukrainiens qui tentent de
quitter la vie
les autorités russes de leur côté
affirment que ce sont les Ukrainiens qui
refusent de partir Daniel
le Comité international de la
Croix-Rouge se dit très inquiet de la
situation sur place et décrit des scènes
déchirantes pour les habitants le CIC à
se dit aussi prêt à faciliter le passage
des civils dès qu'un accord humanitaire
sera trouvé un troisième round de
négociation doit se tenir ce weekend